gleicher position nicht frings in die
mittelrheinliga dafür ist wirklich so
schlecht gemacht es ist einfach
unglaublich leute heute ist schon der 23
12 dem morgen ist weihnachten
wo ist dieses jahr hin denk ich mir die
umwelt durch dieses video aufnahme leute
aber so oder so leute egal ob das jahr
euch genauso wie mir sehr sehr kurz vor
kann man einfach nichts passiert ist in
diesem jahr einfach nichts machen konnte
ist ist soweit heute das jahr nähert
sich seinem ende und das ist für uns
noch mal zurück zu schauen und ein
bisschen zu reflektieren und mit dem
jahr abzuschließen und deswegen hab ich
mir gedacht leute schließen wir auch
eine sache ab die dieses jahr und sehr
auf begleitet hat und schauen wir uns
das erste hilf mir video auf youtube an
ich hab mir zu diesem zwecke
selbstständig professionelle
unterstützung geholt ohne die dieses
video nicht möglich wäre
danke an dieser stelle nochmal die na'vi
auf meinem schoß die menschen mich auf
dieses video reagieren wird was geht
leute lasst die zerstörung beginnen das
erste video aller zeiten heißt die
nächste heidi klum der weg zum model
dasein ist hart vor über zwei jahren
hochladen vor über zwei jahren liegen
diese ganze scheiße los auf youtube
leute schauen wir rein let's go
er weißt du als model verdienst du
10.000 euro pro tag man hat er ein
jetset-leben die typen legen ein zu
füßen
das ist die tragische sache leute hilft
mir ist ja auch schon in der heutigen
form also canaria mit über sechs jahre
daran gearbeitet auf youtube auch schon
über zwei jahre videos hochgeladen immer
weiter gesteigert auch die heutige form
ist ja nicht so dass man sich sagt okay
jetzt angeschaut mein lebendes besser in
irgendeiner form das ist ja in aller
regel nicht dadurch aber wenn zudem
sowieso schon sehr fragwürdigen konzept
von hefe noch dazu kommt dass man auch
noch keine ahnung und erfahrung mit der
umsetzung von diesem konzept hat somit
den ersten youtube videos hier dann
passieren solche sachen wie das die
adina hast du lass mich runter du
hässlicher menschenaffe bevor ich dich
töten
genau wie laura machen sich viele junge
mädchen etwas vor die realität im
model-business sieht anders aus
swatch swatch flexi erstarrten stefan
bartels da einfach ein ehemann aber
krass ist komplett anders als alle
anderen folgen
ich denke dieses format gar nicht so die
sagen irgendwas und dann gibt's ein
reality check machen sie es jetzt nach
jedem satz zur keine ahnung wie es sie
laura die blonde laura laura sagt zu der
himmel ist blau und dann kommt der
reality check von stefan bartels mit der
rolex oder wie und soja
der himmel ist tatsächlich blau wir
weiter zum nächsten satz
hey was ist das was ich dickköpfig wie
dieses video aufgebaut ist das macht es
macht einfach keinen sinn so
normalerweise erzählen dir doch einfach
ihre stories und dann im nach 34 minuten
werde und was schlimmes passiert kommt
der kommentar hier ist einfach so ich
verstehe das einfach nicht
die net bitte bitte einmal einen
kommentar von dir
okay ganz kurz aussagen noch einmal
hochleben und deine familie ist
geschichte doch es lohnt
so sieht ein model aus und nicht so wie
du wirst du siehst aus wie ein
streichholz man sich leisten
ich hätte ich checke dieses ich schrecke
dieses video einfach nicht leute es ist
nicht so dass das video thrashers ich
checke das einfach nicht
also was ist der was ist der aufbau so
ich habe keine ahnung wie dieses video
strukturiert dass die pfälzer war nicht
vor allem also okay wir kurz darauf eine
sache eingehen die schwarzhaarige bisher
die blonde so nach dem motto du hast
kein model körper models haben viel
größere brüste erster nein so wurde ist
jetzt zumindest meines wissens nicht
dafür bekannt dass jetzt die krank
größten brüste der welt haben zweitens
habe ich sagen ja
hallo ich habe mal eine frage zu einem
beratungsgespräch
das ist der aufbau von diesem video
dicker das nach nur zehn sekunden
einwendungen aus sachen die gar nicht
logisch aufeinander folgen dazu kommt
auch leute ich mir müssen ansprechen
ihre stimme ist auf jeden fall
interessant ich kann das sein als jemand
der selbst als man die pubertät
durchgang hat mit allen punkten in
seinem leben wo man auch einmal anfängt
zu jodeln mitten im satz und jedes mal
dafür gerettet wurde
ja sie hat das auch so
also leute ich muss wirklich sagen ich
habe es noch unterschätzt wie an dass
diese erste folge ist ich hab so
genannter schätze ich dachte so jacobi
die wird man schon ein bisschen schlecht
ist ein bisschen frischer aber das ist
ja ganz anders ganz anders aufgebaut
sein sie ist einzige was ihr
kontinuierliches so nice ist mein bruder
stefan bartels mit der rolli am start
aber das auch alles
siehst du hier ist keine story du
vollidiot rede ich chinesisch
also das ist ja wirklich selbst für also
es macht einfach keinen sinn leute
selbst behindert korrekt in der mitten
im video dankeschön also wollte ich
meine selbst so die größten träsch
sendung die es gibt in deutschland haben
eigentlich immer ein klares format sonne
also man weiß abc passiert ok und es ist
ungefähr dass das ist einfach so jetzt
ist es hier weil man beim fotoshooting
so es wird keine story zu ihr erzählt
als die ratgeberserie hilft mir wieder
mal zur stelle leute versuchten sich
models zu werden weil ihr müsst in high
heels springen und brechen könnte so
läuft das bei 90 prozent aller
interessenten nicht verstaubt ich bin
gar nicht bin ich keine einzige denke so
ein bisschen bis ins haus bekommt was
sie da wir bisher sehr verdächtig dass
jetzt gerade 3,4 nahe kommt so liegt das
auch an der typ zu sein ist okay
also ich habe dieses setting schon mal
gesehen
in anderen videos endlich mal ein
erst mal sehen was wir haben ja das war
was du willst du da haben sie ist ein
mal gesprungen hat sich direkt die
kirche gebrochen was sollte was soll da
für fotos bei entstanden sein
sagt mal ganz errichtet egal ich habe
jetzt noch einmal auf den ablöse aus
dieser beträgt und dass ihr der kirche
gebrochen aber lasst doch einfach mal
gucken was wir haben
das ist wirklich so schlecht gemacht das
ist so schlecht gemacht die kamera
er drückt einmal auf den auslöser
wow das eine bild wobei knöchelbruch ist
nicht geil nicht weil die für duisburg
aber ich bin schockiert wirklich bin
überrascht und sieht man soll dann wohl
sei es würde ich nicht bereit für den
modeljob also ich bin schockiert
wirklich einmal auf den auslöser drücken
reicht nicht aus bei dir das ja das wird
nichts mit einem post und wie man sich
vor der kamera bewegt das kann man alles
lernen was man nicht lernen kann ist das
gewisse etwas und das hast du das feuer
[Musik]
in diesem setting ist so creepy der du
gibst mir das ganze ding ich will gar
nicht irgendwann in die ecke stellen und
beim namen nennen aber das ganze setting
gibt mir ein bisschen krieg weil ja
finde ich nicht okay abstand
professional abstand folgen weil sie
einfach sie sind halt wirklich aus wie
die jungen aus sie ist wirklich um sie
könnte auch 13 sein oder so er ist hilft
nicht mehr 13 also braucht ja ich weiß
das kommt für model agenten und
fotografen vielleicht überraschend dass
man mit minderjährigen nicht anfangen
sollte aber trotzdem ich kann dir helfen
kann nicht kuschen
das kostet allerdings 500 euro
diese einblendung immer so also ich
weiss leute ich will jetzt wirklich
jemand displays becken aber frage hilft
mir vorher früher an als so ein programm
für hörgeschädigte ganz ehrlich die
frage an der stelle weil einfach es wird
jedes mal wenn von der zahl die rede ist
die zahl einfach eingeblendet so so
danke schön aber gott sei dank mit mir
von ihr noch alle alle sinne so ich kann
auch noch hören eigentlich was auf 1500
euro
aber wenn die hier und jetzt dazu
entscheide es ist das jahr 1200 euro
freundschaftspreis
das ist so schlecht ist macht einfach
gar keinen sinn also ich kann es mir
auch nicht erklären
die einzige erklärung nicht mehr im kopf
habe ist dass sie vielleicht ein paar so
eine lange fernseh folge hatten und
haben doch überhaupt überhaupt keine
ahnung hatten wie sie das in youtube
videos schneiden und dann einfach das
dabei herausgekommen ist also leute ich
weiß ich weiß auch nicht ob wir haben
genug gesehen und dass wir zu beurteilen
wie jetzt die letzte chance für dich
hier nochmal ins mikro was zu sagen ich
bin ein besseres modell als das mädchen
mit der achterbahn stimme dann leute
diesen sind wir verabschieden die noch
nicht und wir wünschen euch ganz ganz
frohe weihnachten richtig cooles fest
bleibt gesund sorgt dafür dass alle in
eurem umkreis auch gesund bleiben wir
wissen wie das geht natürlich vor das
video online kanal
wir sind schon raus macht gut